I have to be a princess and you are dear
digital artist Helen Morgan has
reimagined Disney Princesses as some of
our favorite celebrities and we're in
love join us as we ponder what the
princesses would have been like if
they'd been portrayed by these ladies
keep watching to the end to discover
which Disney Princess has been recreated
as four different stars one of whom is a
big sneak peak for fans of live-action
remakes what do you think do you like it
we're starting with the artists favorite
portrait from her series and that's her
very first picture from back in August
2018 Rachel McAdams is a designer
Cinderella and a Zuhair Murad dress and
Jimmy two-shoes we'd love it if Rachel
brought a touch of Regina George's Queen
B sass from Mean Girls to the character
just imagine that of course there's
already been a live-action remake of
Cinderella with Lily James as the lead
do you think a Rachel would have been a
better choice you're like really pretty
thank you
so you agree in the artists 21st century
update Snow White swaps her poisoned
piece of fruit for an Apple phone
instead and Lily Collins is just perfect
as the first-ever princess Walt Disney
created that's because she's already
played the part in the 2012 movie Mira
Mira they need to see who you really are
you can watch Helens process in the
speedpaints video she uploads to her
YouTube channel just see how the image
emerges right down to the blue
nail-polish Moana is one of the artists
favorite princesses so Selena Gomez is
honored to be cast in the role with that
wavy dark hair it totally works visually
but do the two have anything in common
well Moana has magic water powers and
Selena certainly knows a thing or two
about magic after all she starred as
Alex Russo in the magical Disney Channel
series Wizards of Waverly Place you're
beautiful I'm going to keep painting you
we've already seen Val represented by
Emma Watson in the live-action remake
but Helens recreation of the book loving
princess has a much darker edge just
look at Millie Bobby Brown's nose and
that broken glass it totally fits the
stranger things actress as the artist
says Millie is a beauty who always has a
monster in her work more than a year
earlier Helen recreated Belle as a
million arc in a much more bookish pose
which is your favorite speaking of emma
watson when the artist wanted to
recreate Anna from frozen - she chose
this English actress to step into the
part as we know Emma completely gets
what it takes to be a Disney Princess my
father taught me to dance
I used to step on his toes a lot but we
can't help but think the smart Hermione
is more suited to being bookish Belle
than enthusiastic Anna a year previously
Helen recreated Anna as Cara Delevingne
which do you prefer
every Anna needs an Elsa and Helen has
given those Ice Queen honours to Margot
Robbie the artist has a special place in
her heart for Elsa as she always dressed
as a Snow Queen at Christmas parties as
a child she also recreated Elsa as
Margot a year earlier it's interesting
to see the changes between the two
portraits showing the differences in
Elsa between the two films the
Australian actor knows how to play an
iconic Disney woman having portrayed
Jane in The Legend of Tarzan in 2016 you
must know that this is a very picture
Lee Jane from Tarzan was intended to be
part of the official Disney Princess
lineup in 1999 but was removed as her
colour scheme was too similar to Belle's
as we've seen Margot Robbie portrayed
her in the live-action remake but Helen
chose to recreate Jane as Elizabeth
Olsen in her series of portraits
Elizabeth has such a perfect look of
sophistication in this recreation of
course that's quite the change from her
part in the Marvel Cinematic Universe as
Scarlet Witch but that's what acting is
all about being adaptable it's your
fault it's everyone's fault who cares
when it comes to choosing who would be
Merida you automatically think of her
flowing red hair so it's no surprise
that the artist recreated the Scottish
picks our princess from brave as Emma
Stone just take a look at the photo
versus art side-by-side comparison Emma
would be amazing play in this feisty
character speaking of feisty characters
Breanna is a strong confident woman in
Tiana from The Princess and the Frog
certainly knows what she wants and goes
for it they both understand the
importance of hard work I gotta make
sure all daddy's hard work means
something after all RiRi works pretty
hard as petty officer Cora rakes in the
2012 sci-fi action movie Battleship you
only need to look at that steely
determination in her eye in the
side-by-side photo versus art comparison
to know this is a fitting recreation
Rapunzel is such a dreamer so full of
optimism and enthusiasm and that really
reminds us of Amanda Seyfried
particularly her role as Sofia in the
Mamma Mia movies sounds I know you so
we're super pleased if the artist chose
to recreate the long-haired princess as
this actress not to mention of course
the fact that they look like carbon
copies of each other that blonde hair
those big eyes
Helen has totally nailed this recreation
Disney might have created Aurora many
decades before Rapunzel but the two
princesses have a lot in common
they're both dreamers and they both have
skills with food
Rapunzel bakes while Aurora goes off to
collect berries in the forest which
weakens soci Blake Lively doing she
describes herself as a foodie and a cook
and Martha Stewart is her idol so we're
really pleased to see that Helen
recreated Aurora as a Blake she looks
the part too right given that Disney
Princesses love to sing it makes sense
to choose a singer Camila Cabello would
bring so much fun to the part of Jasmine
and she's already getting experience in
the world of Disney Princesses not as
Jasmine though but as Cinderella in
Sony's live-action musical adaptation of
the tale isn't it cute how she has a cat
rather than a tiger in the portrait and
just check out that bling
Helen also created a porch
Naomi Scot who played Jasmine in the
2019 live-action remake of Aladdin what
did you say do you trust me although
Lucy Liu didn't star in Disney's 2020
live-action remake of Mulan
she got Helens vote as the perfect
person for the parts when the artist was
deciding whom to recreate the brave
soldier as she chose the actor who's
shown her action credentials many times
we only have to mention Charlie's Angels
but there are plenty of other action
movies lucy has started in this
recreation lucy is dressed as Mulan her
long haired and rogue days rather than
in her days as peeing the soldier we'd
love to see that recreation - just my
toot but the artist chose a pop star
from Britain for the part of Pocahontas
and that's leigh-anne Pinnock
from the girl group Little Mix with her
long straight dark hair she's just
perfect for the iconic scene when the
wind lifts Pocahontas locks up where
they belong
Twitter fan accounts have compared LeAnn
to the Disney princess before - we can't
help but wonder which Disney Princesses
should be recreated as the other members
of Little Mix let us know what you think
in the comment section although the
title character from Alice in Wonderland
isn't an official Disney princess many
fans consider her part of the group
she's been included in Disney Princess
sing-along CDs after all and isn't
Riverdale's Lily Reinhart interesting as
the curious blonde haired character she
certainly gives her an edge we love how
she's not as cutesy as other depictions
and the Cheshire Cat looks cutting to
three months before this portrait helen
had recreated Alice as Amber Heard which
version do you prefer Kida is an
inspirational character she becomes
Queen in her movie Atlantis the lost
Empire although she's not an official
Disney Princess she's part of the larger
group and she wears awesome makeup who
else is as inspiring and unique the
singer Billie Eilish of course she's
totally rockin those marks on her cheek
and quite frankly you should see her in
a crown we'd love to see her adopt this
for one of her music videos princess
vanellope von schweetz may only be nine
years old but she's not someone to be
reckoned with and who better to recast
her as ariana grande the star of record
valve actually brought all the other
princesses together in her sequel Ralph
breaks the Internet and even got them to
wear casual clothes I guess it's back to
the gowns girls it was lovely to meet
you vanellope so it's more than
appropriate that ariana is wearing
vanilla peas green hoodie those candy
hair accessories really suit her - don't
you just love how Ariana's finger tattoo
has been recreated to spell out
vanellope genius mogera and megan fox
are a perfect pair they both share the
same shortened first name when helen
recreated the character from the 1997
movie hercules she chose the
Transformers actor to take on the part
and we're loving her red hair although
we're most used to seeing Megan with
dark hair she dyed her locks red in 2013
for her role in the live-action Ninja
Turtles movie yeah that's what family's
for rats
and if Megan sees this portrait of
herself as the feisty character from
Hercules we think she'd be keen to go
back to be in a red head we feel for
poor Esmeralda from the 1996 movie The
Hunchback of Notre Dom she was one part
of the official lineup of Disney
Princesses but she's been off the list
for several years now
however Pelin is still interested enough
in the kind character to recreate her as
a celebrity and she chose Mila Kunis to
step into the role the actor knows what
it's like to portray a fairytale
character she played the Wicked Witch of
the West in the 2013 fantasy film oz the
great and powerful deep down you are
wicked with a big purple ribbon and big
gold hoops Mila looks just right as as
Marella now with her husband Ashton
Kutcher be willing to take on the part
of captain Phoebus we're not so sure
we're finishing with Ariel recreated as
Holly Bailey the actor who has the honor
of playing The Little Mermaid in the
upcoming live-action remake this
portrait gives fans a sneak peek of how
Ariel could actually look on the screen
including a speedpaint video but that's
all the artists also recreated the
Little Mermaid as three other celebs
Alyssa Milano Nina Dobrev and sophie
Turner which one do you prefer check out
more of Helens amazing portraits over at
her Instagram account at Helen
underscore Morgan and before you go tell
us which one of Helens recreations stood
out to you the most in the comment
section below who made your gown I've
never seen anything quite like it please
give us a big thumbs up and remember to
hit that subscribe button to be the
first to watch our latest videos thanks
for watching
you